when most people try and get a new job
they search for a listing
then they apply and then they wait
search apply
wait over and over again this is
all wrong i've hired over a hundred
people in my career
and today i'm going to explain exactly
how to get a new job
in just three weeks hunting for a new
job can feel daunting and believe me
i've been there but i promise you that
there is a right way
and a wrong way to go about finding a
new job the method i'm going to outline
doesn't just apply to finding a job it
works in sales
operations and even fundraising i've
actually used this exact technique
to raise over 100 million dollars for my
businesses if you're new here i'm john
i live in los angeles california and
have been an entrepreneur for the past
decade
every week i put out new videos about
technology startups so please hit that
subscribe button and ring the bell so
you don't miss any let me walk you
through how most people apply for jobs
and then explain why it takes forever
and rarely gets results
first you start searching around for job
postings casually bouncing between
websites until you find something that
looks interesting then you read the post
and see if you could qualify
usually the job description is extremely
long and vague with dozens of
qualifications that sometimes contradict
one another then after you finally find
something that looks good
you fill out an application and start to
wait if you don't hear back
you start to look for another job
listing but this is extremely slow
then even after you've applied you have
to wade through several rounds of phone
screens and interviews
to find out if you even got the job i
see people doing this all the time
and it always takes them forever to land
a new job this can be really dangerous
because
for better or worse lots of human
resource departments are trained to
filter out candidates with resume gaps
meaning that more than a few months have
passed between jobs
following this process of search apply
interview is terrible
and can lead to a downward spiral where
it actually gets harder
the longer you work at it but there's a
much better way essentially
instead of doing one step after the
other you want to do
everything in parallel that means
instead of just searching for a single
job posting
you need to collect hundreds of postings
before you fill out a single application
getting a job is just like selling a
product it's impossible to have a 100
conversion rate so you need to
acknowledge that up front
apple has one of the best brands in the
world and some really great marketing to
push their products
but not every apple advertisement is
going to lead to a customer purchase
so they spread their bets out and market
their products broadly
let's break the entire job hunting
process down into three key steps
which could be done one week at a time
first up is what i call research and
development and this is what happens
before you apply to a single job posting
this whole process is about being as
efficient as possible
so it's important to do all of your
research in parallel
your goal here is to build a massive
list of prospects
that you can reach out to in step two so
organization is key
instead of searching for job postings in
this stage you need to search for
companies and more specifically
individual people who have the authority
to hire you
start by listing out every company that
operates in whatever industry you were
just working in
then expand out based on your specific
skill set so if you've been working in
marketing at an electronics company
start by finding as many electronics
companies as possible
then broadening out to any company with
a growing marketing department
don't try and filter too much at this
stage instead just focus on gathering as
much information as possible
and compiling everything in a
spreadsheet if you're used to using a
tool like notion or airtable
you can definitely use those but google
sheets is fine too
just make sure to note the name of the
company and how big they are
working for a small company can be
dramatically different than working for
a large corporation
so it's worthwhile to keep size in mind
you can usually find out how many
employees a particular company has by
searching linkedin
or just google applying for jobs is
really a sales process
and not every lead is going to convert
into a job offer so you want to maximize
your top of funnel
leads by collecting as many potential
opportunities as possible
it's not crazy to compile a list of over
a hundred potential companies before you
start applying
if you spend five minutes researching
each company you should be able to
compile a list of a hundred companies in
just one day once you have all these
companies in your spreadsheet
start developing your leads this is
where you start to find job listings and
contact
information for managers who hire people
with your skills
you should be adding information to each
row in your spreadsheet
so you wind up with names and contact
information for every target company
this is also a good time to start
developing your personal elevator pitch
as you research these companies and
start seeing patterns in what they're
hiring for
try to imagine how you would fit into
the organization there's often a big
mismatch between the title of the job
and the description below
at google a software engineer might be
expected to have a computer science
degree
and really understand algorithms whereas
a small company
outside the tech industry might still be
hiring a software engineer but
really just needs someone who can build
a simple website you want to figure out
what skills you have and what skills are
immediately adjacent to your experience
if you feel like you're lacking a
specific skill now is a great time to go
and learn more
if you've been programming for a few
years but don't really have any
experience with design
take time before your job search fully
gets going to try and get up to speed
with the basics of that discipline
you can't become an expert in just one
week but it never hurts to be more
well-rounded then comes step
two parallel outreach this is really the
heart of this entire process
hr departments are notoriously slow to
process job applications
and you never want to be in a position
where you're just waiting to hear back
about a job
and have nothing to do in a great
scenario maybe 10
of job applications are going to turn
into interviews so you really need to
fill up your lead spreadsheet before you
start reaching out
the goal is to only go through this
process once and then just decide
between multiple job offers at the end
but you can obviously repeat the cycle
if need be the key is to keep the top
of the funnel as big as possible so
every stage has the maximum chance of
converting
applying to multiple jobs can be really
daunting and it's not uncommon to think
that you should just focus all of your
energy on a single posting
and spend an entire week preparing for
that but that's a huge mistake
the first stage of any hiring process is
basically just a filter
you might be the perfect candidate for a
position and spend
weeks preparing an amazing application
only to find out that they just hired
someone a week ago
and forgot to close out the job listing
so you need to standardize your process
for applying
you don't want to spam people but a
little bit of process optimization can
go a long way here
after all if you're serious about
applying to a hundred jobs in one go
you can't spend much time on each one so
you need to create a workflow for
efficiency
you can use a tool like mail merge to
automatically fill out personalized
emails
but sometimes this can backfire even if
you add personal details like the name
of the person you're emailing
it can still feel like a marketing email
where there were clearly just a few
holes that got filled in automatically
instead you should have a few lines of
boilerplate about yourself
and then customize the rest in your
spreadsheet you should have
the name of the company and the name of
the person you're reaching out to which
is a good starting point
if you have time be sure to add in a few
details about the position and why you
want to work for the company
this is a great place to show that you
did some research and mention a recent
announcement
by the company that you couldn't have
possibly just autofilled
the key here is to stick to a schedule
if your target is to apply to a hundred
companies in a single week you shouldn't
spend more than 25 minutes per company
that should be plenty of time if you're
well organized and have all of your
supporting materials
like a resume and links to relevant work
experience all together already in one
place
as you're applying really try and figure
out what steps you have to repeat over
and over again so you can automate them
tools like auto hotkey and textexpander
can create macros to keep you from
typing the same sentence
over and over again regardless of
whether you use mac
or pc there are great options to speed
up your process
and i'll leave some links to helpful
resources right below the like button
step 3 is what i call targeted
interviewing it's easy to treat every
interview the same way
and put your maximum effort into each
one but that's actually a common error
interviewing for a new job should be as
much about you deciding whether or not
you want the job
as the company deciding whether or not
they want to hire you
job postings can be very misleading and
it's not always the company's fault the
hiring manager could be using an old
template or the company's goals could
have shifted
since they put up the job rack either
way you can't fall into the trap of
thinking that you have to see
every interview process to the end far
too many managers would love to hire
someone who's a bit overqualified
and you don't want to end up being that
someone it's important to validate early
on in the interview process
exactly what you'll be doing and assess
whether or not that's a fit for you
you might have done a particular job a
few years ago and hated it
so even though you're technically
qualified you need to filter out any
companies that want you to do that
terrible
job there are two added benefits to this
more aggressive approach
first taking an active interest in the
position and really digging in to see if
it's what you want to be doing for the
next few years
shows a lot of initiative and that looks
great in interviews
second declining to advance to the next
round after a phone screen reveals that
a job isn't quite right for you
builds your confidence if you followed
the first two steps properly
you should have plenty of interviews
going on simultaneously
and never feel like you have to take a
job because it's the only opportunity
available
this strategy is all about parallelism
and if you do it right
you'll wind up in a great situation
where you can actually decide between
multiple job offers and weigh the pros
and cons of each one
you might even be able to negotiate for
a higher salary at the most interesting
company
because you have some real leverage even
though companies are legally limited in
what they can ask you about your job
search
most managers can actually sense when a
candidate that they really want to hire
has multiple offers even if you don't
say it explicitly
so use this to your advantage if you'd
like to go a bit deeper
just drop your email at johncoogan.com
and please check out this recommended
video
the youtube algorithm thinks that you'll
really like it